sta mio certificato
la mia assicurazione professionale
quello che mi interessava mostrare il
fatto che in architettura l'idea di
durabilità e legata all'idea di
responsabilità qualsiasi sia la
costruzione noi facciamo in realtà
forniamo una garanzia per dieci anni
una garanzia del nostro operato
quindi il tempo minimo legale per
l'architettura sono dieci anni però in
realtà il dibattito su quanto debba
durare un architettura è qualcosa che
vede posizioni estremamente diverse da
sempre io ve ne leggo due che mi
sembrano interessanti un e giancarlo de
carlo italiano che dice io quando
progetto progetto per sempre e non mi
passa neanche per la mente che quello
che progetto potrebbe durare soltanto
poco tempo toyo ito giapponese ci dice
non abbiamo bisogno di altre forme di
architettura se non quelle che come
immagini televisive appaiono per un
evento e spariscono quando l'evento
finisce
ancora più bello le opere d'architettura
non sono dissimili da deperibili filetti
di pesce avvolti in un foglio di
cellophane su uno scaffale di un negozio
di surgelati come
nuova generazione e quindi generazione
che coscienze cosciente del tema della
sostenibilità in realtà vedendo le
immagini che sono prodotte nello stesso
periodo di de carlo questi architetti
contemporanei al decano che costruivano
perdurare sempre dobbiamo chiederci in
realtà esiste un alchimia esiste un tra
virgolette una formula magica che
permette ad un'architettura di restare o
di essere obsoleta è un po tutto il
nostro lavoro porta su questa idea di
costruire forme che in realtà
restano in movimento forme che evolvono
col tempo
ancora un link a aldo rossi che la forma
presideva la costruzione permaneva in
uno dove le funzioni si modificavano
continuamente e nella forma si modifica
il materiale
quello che è interessante che già nel
post moderno si dice che la forma
praticante sopravvive alla funzione e
quindi l'idea ecco cos'è questa forma in
movimento cliché lo dice benissimo che
c'è la forma non è un risultato
acquisito un finale una conclusione
bisogna pensarla come genesi come volumi
movimento il suo essere e il divenire la
forma e con apparenza non è che una
maligna apparizione cioè la forma non è
come le cose ci appaiono ma è qualcosa
di astratto che è all'interno delle cose
il nostro tre progetti
che sono tre evoluzioni di forme
il primo si trova in a bag vicino
bordeaux e al limite praticamente della
città ed è stata costruita
sull'eredità concettuale del dell'epoca
moderna l'eredità in cui abbiamo
lasciato l'idea della città continua
abbiamo cominciato a fare i blocchi
distanti uno dall'altro
monofunzionali per abitazioni sperando
di tutte le ragioni igieniche
allontanandoli creare un mondo più verde
migliore ma il risultato e soprattutto
in francia dove se si pensa ai 36 posti
più violenti della francia sono 36 si
deve 36 estratti da forse
una cattiva interpretazione dei principi
moderni comunque sono posti in cui non
si sa qual è lo spazio privato con lo
spazio collettivo quale lo spazio
pubblico per cui in realtà è un
territorio di nessuno territorio di
nessuno diventa rapidamente territorio
di quello che pensa di essere il più
forte e sfocia in violenza
per neve che questo quartiere dove ci
hanno chiamato lui el noel mamère è
diventato sindaco e del presidente dei
verdi ha fatto due cose straordinarie
la prima che ha unito il centro a bordo
quindi ha esteso
la connessione della città e la seconda
è che ha distrutto tutto ed è stato
veramente benvenuto da tutti e su queste
macerie ha lanciato un concorso
internazionale che è stato vinto da uno
studio olandese con un'idea
semplicissima che era quella di dire
facciamo dei grandi delle grandi
architetture che per la loro
cala riescono a definire lo spazio
pubblico per questi tre lotti
solo che all'inizio in questo progetti
questa visione di costruire masse con le
architetture per definire gli spazi
pubblici chiedevano 14mila metri quadri
2008 è arrivato la crisi è venuta e
quindi al posto non c'erano più
investitori al posto di 14mila sono
richiesti solo 7mila e quindi in realtà
c'era una parte non costruita questo
grigio che era interessantissima nel
processo perché per noi era il
territorio dove la forma poteva muoversi
dove in qualche modo c'era spazio per
dare del potenziale ha un volume che era
già fermo e quindi al tempo allo studio
ci chiedevamo come riuscire a unire le
qualità della casa unifamiliare con la
qualità dell'immobile collettivo e
quindi abbiamo cercato una forma che
potesse ibridare questi due sistemi e
l'abbiamo fatto sovrapponendo delle
unità tra di loro e che quindi ogni se
immaginate uno di questo una casa in
realtà lui non abcd di a sinistra né a
destra né sopra né sotto e può
utilizzare il tetto del vicino per
raddoppiare la propria superficie
questo modello astratto l'abbiamo poi
applicato al territorio e ne abbiamo
fatto degli immobili
degli immobili in cui
vendevano praticamente gli investitori
vendevano 80 metri quadri con la
possibilità in funzione dell'evoluzione
della famiglia di raddoppiarsi con chi
in questi vuoti che non erano costruiti
ci hanno fatto vincere il concorso che
era un'assurdità perché nella società
perché
l'edificio farà solo sette metri di
larghezza ogni stanza a tre esposizioni
da sulla strada sulla corte e sul
proprio giardino ed è economicamente un
modello non viabile perché al posto di
costruire una facciata ne facciamo
quattro per cellula quindi ci siamo
dovuti inventare il modo per rendere
tutto ciò realtà realtà in un'equazione
economica molto ristretto arca è stato
costruito a 1.000 euro al metro quadro e
poi realtà venderlo in seguito quindi
abbia fatto un po come un parcheggio
tutto si è prefabbricato c'erano sei
moduli che permetteva di fare le tre
architetture in funzione di quello che
certo l'abbiamo finito da poco questo è
chiuso questo è quando si apre ed ogni
appartamento a raddoppiare la propria
superficie e hanno comprato praticamente
questo è stato gratuito ed è stato
quello che siamo riusciti a lavorare con
la città di di bordo
quindi la partenza molto austeri
quindi in questo primo progetto la forma
trova lo spazio per muoversi nel vuoto
c'è il vuoto è quello carico di
potenziale per il futuro
il secondo progetto che vi posso dire
altro non c'è assolutamente vuoto siano
a parigi nord di parigi
l'unico quartiere che si costruisce ora
che il diciassettesimo su un
modello che un po questa città ecologica
che stanno costruendo di tutta europa
cioè un parco con dei blocchi attorno si
chiamano gli architetti gli si da un
blocco in funzione del talento di ogni
architetto arriviamo immagini del genere
maneggiare che stanno diventando globali
e che a me sinceramente non ricordano
affatto parigi e non riesco a vedere il
nesso tra il modo di fare la città di un
tempo è quello di oggi per cui ci siamo
interrogati in questo progetto su che si
trova al limite qui è al limite di
questo grandissimo nuovo intervento è
molto molto vicino a quello che io stimo
essere uno dei sistemi urbani più
intelligenti che esista che quello
sarebbe stato il modello os maniano
parigi è la città più densa d'europa è
un estrusione di sette piani costante
sia plafon parisiano costante di tutta
la città tranne rare eccezioni ed è
stata costruita tutta 70 per cento della
città in 120 anni
grazie a questi uomini ma soprattutto
grazie ousman aveva fatto due cose molto
interessanti che erano l'obbligo di un
alcun tipo di facciata per tutti i nuovi
immobili è un regolamento per gli
investimenti privati grazie a questi due
sistemi ha creato quello che si chiama
l'edificio smaniano l'edificio smaniano
è uno delle forme con un intelligenza
assolutamente affascinante in soli due
secoli creati per abitarci all'inizio
abitazione borghese sono diventati
uffici scuole musei poi sono ritornate
abitazioni sono ritornati uffici cioè
nello stesso nella stessa struttura
urbana in realtà il patrimonio riusciva
a seguire l'evoluzione socio economica
della città e poi c'è un'identità
fortissima che caratterizza praticamente
tutta la città 15 sun chiesti ma qual è
l'alchimia qual è questo segreto che fa
che questo tipo di architettura resta
per due secoli e può fare tutto e
abbiamo cominciato ad analizzarla la
prima cosa che
insomma è abbastanza evidente che il
ritmo di facciata e le aperture
nonostante sembra monolitico in realtà
sono 65 per cento più o meno di vetro ma
soprattutto queste finestre regolari
permettono di disegnare qualsiasi pianta
dietro se vogliamo una stanza letto
vendiamo una finestra un soggiorno due
finestre un ufficio una finestra
eccetera eccetera insomma da una
flessibilità nel progetto che abbastanza
interessante in seguito da un'offerta di
altezze tra i piani che è completamente
in contraddizione con l'eredità
dell'architettura moderna che stiamo
utilizzando ora cioè oggi quando voi
fate alloggi in europa avete un altezza
di piano di due metri e 80 se fate degli
uffici tre metri e 50 significa che
lavorate su un'idea di risposta ad una
funzione
monofunzionale che non ha possibilità di
evolvere in house ma partiamo dal piano
terra abbiamo quattro metri poi c'è 2 80
poi si e 330 e poi c'è 4 metri ancora e
poi ancora due tanti insomma c'è un
pannello di offerta che permetta a
nell'insieme la stessa forma di riuscire
a far coabitare differenti funzioni
un altra cosa interessante stato
l'architettura è estremamente compatta
questa compattezza è il primo passo per
il risparmio energetico
un altro punto è che la struttura è
chiarissima quindi si sa come
intervenire
e l'ultimo punto è che ogni pezzo di
questa architettura a una riserva
commerciale variabile che anima e che fa
tutto all'interazione con lo spazio
pubblico della città cioè c'è il piano
terra e commerciale che può diventare
anche il primo piano senza passare dalla
connessione dell'immobile e questo cioè
un mcdonald prende piano terra e primo
piano un applauso di solo piano terra il
primo piano diventa abitazione ma questo
riesce a dare un profilo variabile a
tutto il bisogno della città su tutta la
sua superficie
insomma abbiamo cercato e lo sapevano
già il tempo quando si ci si vedeva di
queste sezioni abbiamo cercato di
riprodurre questi principi in chiave
contemporanea quindi abbiamo fatto un
architettura in cui abbiamo portato in
facciata tutta la struttura
liberando quindi l'interno con la
possibilità di muovere le mura quando ci
serviva abbiamo scelto un'altezza tra i
piani di tre metri e venti che è un po
un intermedio tra alloggi e uffici
ma chi lascia abbastanza la porta aperta
abbiamo lavorato su questa idea del
piano terra variabile
abbiamo chiarito tutto e con una sola
finestra tra nata su un metro e 35 che
non numero d'oro per fare gli uffici
abbiamo abbiamo ricostituito la forma
tutti gli spazi esterni sono estrusioni
negativo di questa finestra quindi se
domani non si vuole la loggia l'asi
risposta nel primo piano e questo è già
nel tempo del concorso mostravano come
l'immobile poteva funzionare in alloggi
ed uffici in più abbiamo radicalizzato
questa scelta passando tutta la tecnica
nella facciata elettricità acqua
struttura o con stazione solare tutto
passa in un modulo prefabbricato che
questo che lui si assembla uno
sull'altro ricostruendo finalmente
l'immagine che questa questa è la
facciata oggi quello che divertente
questa trama estremamente radicale in
realtà applicandola sulla parcella
stessa rimanda a un sistema iconografico
che è quello dell'immobile d'angolo
dell'edificio d'angolo parigino
nel suo lato generico poi ha sviluppato
all'inter fatto di aver lavorato
un'architettura senza programma senza ha
fatto comunque sviluppare degli spazi
per per housing che sono estremamente
interessanti e inusuali per parigi
quindi sono molto vetrati come come a
new york hanno di questi sistemi di
logiche che sono dei patio attorno al
quale gira tutta la configurazione
dell'appartamento e questa è la nostra
sezione per come ousman speriamo che nel
2055 avremo una discoteca sul tetto
uffici a destra case a sinistra nel
singoli video eccetera
quindi qua e la forma stessa che diventa
intelligente la forma stessa che si può
muovere che può seguire l'evoluzione
l'ultima è un teatro che abbiamo
cominciato un anno fa e che ha
strasbourg trasmuta due teatri 1 il
teatro nazionale la struttura del maggio
questo è il teatro nazionale
e questo il tratto di maio stato che
maione un teatro è una compagnia alla
quale hanno dato l'uso di unindustria
per produrre la loro propria attività ed
una storia architettura bellissima
perché in realtà a partire dal luogo
hanno rivisto il loro modo di far teatro
e succedeva dieci anni fa in europa che
molti teatri lavoravano a partire dal
luogo fino a creare una rete europea di
teatro contemporaneo e che oggi è stato
più all'avanguardia che si trova questo
è praticamente la programmazione
dell'anno scorso
non so se avete mai sentito queste
queste opere comunque è là dove il
teatro oggi si muove una nuova forma di
teatro che esce completamente dai canoni
che conosciamo questa è la loro sala che
tutto quello che non bisogna fare quando
si fa un teatro non c'è acustica la luce
viene praticamente dal backstage ogni
anno la rifanno la risposta no insomma è
veramente non accademico utilizzano
l'entrata del teatro per cominciare le
rappresentazioni
ricostruiscono scenari assurdi e poi
sono convinti che il teatro deve andare
nella città e quindi si sono costruiti
dei dispositivi dove mettono in scena
ogni settimana delle forme di
rappresentazioni su 24 ore
insomma sono interessantissime sono
sinceramente un po pazzi e devono
risposta rsj questi si erano già sposati
una volta perché il parlamento si
installava in a strasburgo ed orali di
spostano per che costruiscono un
quartiere d'affari quindi spostano dalla
praticamente al nord di dove sono però
loro non vogliono muoversi a questo
teatro perché sono praticante
legatissimi a questo edificio e quando
siamo andati per per il concorso avevamo
capito che in realtà
loro non volevano un teatro non volevano
un teatro classico e quando ci si
interroga su cosa è il teatro classico
c'è una triade che troverete in tutti i
teatri entrata poi
la sala la terra
palco e la logistica queste tre questa
triade a una rappresentazione
architettonica chiarissima
l'entrata è molto vetrata la sala è
sempre sempre una boxe con cui si
controlla praticante luce acustica e la
logistica non la si vede mai dividendo
proprio artisti e pubblico nei due punti
diametralmente opposti quando vediamo il
loro teatro oggi in funzione di come si
muove la sala e dove decidono di rifare
la rappresentazione muovono la logistica
e muovono praticamente il fire e quindi
a un certo punto artisti pubblico e
artisti si ritrovano insieme ad iniziare
lo spettacolo in modo molto informale
quindi lavorando su questa idea
abbiamo cercato una forma che potesse
muoversi a partire dalla quale costringi
davano del degli utili per ricostruire
il teatro ogni volta in un teatro nuovo
è l'unica forma che ci è venuta in mente
era la città la città perché se pensiamo
alla città in realtà quando queste
barcellona
progettando le strade potete immaginare
questo blocco può evolvere questo può
evolvere questo problema vere senza
perdere il senso della città quindi
abbiamo detto vabbè trasliamo questa
idea di di progettare solo ed
esclusivamente le connessioni quindi
abbia fatto una trama sulla quale
abbiamo iscritto una serie di strade
all'interno del teatro basate su e
quindi su tre elementi avevamo un suolo
in cui si facciamo passare tutti i
raccordi per tutti i movimenti che si
possono avere all'interno un read sopra
in cui si va a tutta la tecnica e poi
forniamo direttamente delle mura che si
possono muovere e che configurano questi
spazi per arrivare a degli scenari in
cui questo è quello classico
praticamente con entrata sale e
logistica
poi magari
sia due entrate con due sale e logistica
fino ad arrivare ad una sola mega sala
per esempio per un defilé eccetera
eccetera
questi sono i pannelli che stanno 14
metri questo per esempio in entrata in
versione
vuota con tutti gli elementi bar
dressing eccetera sono gli scatoli
mobili praticante le mura si muovono
fino a chiudere completamente rendere
questo spazio allo spazio di
rappresentazione
la facciata è la stessa dovunque quindi
non c'è più differenza tra un entità o
un'altra ed è puramente la
rappresentazione di quello che è il grid
questa è la corte esterna in versione
mostra in versione questa che romeo
castellucci una delle rappresentazioni
la grande sala insomma ci siamo lanciati
in questa avventura e loro hanno deciso
di mostrare tramite una mostra il teatro
ai loro abbonati e quindi si sono
cominciati ad appropriare ea far variare
l'immagine prima che il teatro esistesse
sono andata a sorpresa alla mostra e
belem e totale i quali questi
costruiranno il teatro che se l'entrata
della vostra questa va benissimo a roma
in versione golf o che i box stober fest
in una vita virtuale
in spiaggia
medio oriente e questa è la mia
preferita grazie